[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW BROGDON: Hey, everybody.
I'm Andrew from
the Flutter team,
here to tell you all about
Flutter Release Preview
2, which was just announced
at the Google Developer Days
keynote.
RP2 is the last preview
expected before Flutter hits
1.0, which is pretty exciting.
Plus, it's got the latest
and greatest widgets,
and new versions of
the engine and tools.
Let's take a look inside.
The big theme for this release
is Cupertino and making
sure devs using Flutter can
create apps that iOS users feel
right at home with.
That's something the team
has put a lot of effort
into recently, and there's
a bunch of new widgets
to show for it.
CupertinoApp, for example,
is similar to the MaterialApp
widget you may already
be familiar with.
It doesn't include any code
for the material package,
and it still provides text
direction, a HeroController,
a navigator, and
all those other root
of your app sort of widgets.
If you're going for a
pure Cupertino experience,
this is the way to get started.
There's also
CupertinoActionSheet-- an alert
that presents the user with
a set of two or more choices
related to the current context.
You can use actions to
define the choices presented
and the event handlers
that get fired when
a user makes their selection.
And I don't want to forget
CupertinoSegmentedControl,
either, which presents a row
of choices from which users
can select a value.
You just define the choices,
and since this is Flutter,
provide the widgets
that it displays.
Release Preview 2 contains more
than just Cupertino, though--
like support for background
execution of dark code.
If your app has some code
that's an execute on a schedule
or in response to location
changes, making that happen
is now a lot easier.
One of the engineers
on the team even
created a Flutter app that
automatically opens his garage
door when he rolls
home on his bicycle.
There are other
new widgets, too.
InheritedModel, for
instance, works a lot
like InheritedWidget
but allows you
to specify a particular
aspect of the inherited data
that your descendant
widget depends on.
That way, the descendant
is only rebuilt
when that particular
property or group
of properties changes, and fewer
rebuilds equals a faster app.
Speaking of performance,
there are also
a number of under-the-hood
tweaks included in Preview 2
that will help keep your
apps running smooth.
For example, the
Flutter engine was
updated to make clipping a
widget's children opt-in,
rather than on by
default. That eliminated
a whole bunch of work for
the compositing system
and improved some of
our on-device benchmarks
by anywhere from 30% to 100%.
Now, you can see how
much smoother the new one
on the right is.
Flutter's impact on
your final app size
has also been improved.
A simple app built for Android
dropped about 2 megs in size
to just over 4.7 megabytes.
And because most
of that difference
is in Flutter's core
multi-platform code,
iOS has seen similar gains.
All right, that's about
it for Release Preview 2.
If you're already using
Flutter, run flutter upgrade
on the command line or through
your IDE plugin of choice
to get the latest code.
And if you haven't yet
given Flutter a try,
just head to flutter.io
to get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]